erasmus is this year celebrating 30
years of bringing people and cultures
together the program started out in 1987
when just over 3,000 students from 11e
you countries took part in the first
exchanges it has since grown to
encompass vocational education and
training school education adult
education youth and sport given nine
million people the chance to have a
formative experience in 33 countries and
beyond
The Rasmus Plus has also been
instrumental in paving the way for
reforming education training and youth
systems
erasmus+ has been proven to have a
hugely positive impact on participants
in higher education he doubles the
chance of participants being employed
just a year after graduating
most of those who undertake a
traineeship abroad one in three is
offered a job by their host company
vocational education and training
participants find their first job faster
and earn 25% more than they would do
otherwise
voluntary experience abroad is
considered a plus by three-quarters of
employers
so the erasmus+ mobility that has only
helped with job prospects erasmus+ has
been enriching lives and opening minds
for 30 years
let's now bill together the future of
erasmus+
[Music]
you